>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> George Barnum: Welcome everybody.
I'm George Barnum.
I'm the president of
the Chesapeake chapter,
and we're delighted
that you're here.
This is the third time that we
have done one of these events
for our [inaudible] fellows.
It seems unbelievable that this
is the third class of [inaudible],
and we're delighted to have
three of the five of us here
and giving presentations.
Mike Denker, known to many of
us in this room but perhaps not
to the fellows so much and to
others, was a really beloved
and faithful member of this chapter.
He was the president
for a long time.
Above and beyond that,
he was really one
of the coolest people
that ever lived.
And when he was taken from
us four or so years ago,
the chapter did a certain amount
of searching around for a way
to honor his contributions to us,
and there were lots and lots of ways
to describe Mike, all of them
laudatory, but he was a builder.
He was a builder by
profession, and he was a builder.
He was a builder of
friendship and of relationships
between students and [inaudible].
So we felt that our Denker
fellowship is a way to sort of honor
that and hope to sort
of carry him on.
Bringing students into the chapter,
getting them hooked up if we can
with people who are active
and working in the chapter,
and also to open up
the wonderful world
of the American Printing
History Association to them.
We're going to be working this
year under [inaudible] to sort
of formalize the Denker fellowship
a little bit more than it has been
in our own heads and to find more
ways to get the fellows together
with people and to
offer more opportunities
than we've done up to this point.
So that will be coming along.
And it is the time of year
when we are recruiting
for the 2017 class of fellows.
So the way that we do this seems to
work best when it's face to face,
when it's somebody knows.
So if you know somebody who
would be a likely person
to be a Denker fellow next year,
about the only requirement we really
have is they have to be a student.
But beyond that, we are
a very broad church here,
and the application process
is hardly even a process.
So talk to Casey or to me
or to Chris [inaudible].
I have a couple of chapter
announcements to make.
We have, thank goodness, a slate
for chapter elections coming up,
and Chris tells me that the
ballots are in the mail.
So look for them and
return them promptly.
And we are going to be planning a
holiday get together of some kind,
so stay tuned and watch
the email for that.
Casey, do you have any words?
>> [inaudible] beautiful
[inaudible] for sale, only $20.
You can find those on the website.
I brought a couple today so
you can take a look at them.
I think those two are already sold.
>> Twenty-five.
>> It's 25 online because
that includes the shipping.
>> And an expert.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> George Barnum: So, without
any further [inaudible] about,
I will introduce Susanne Allen,
who will then pass it
along to the other two.
Susanne, please.
>> Susanne Allen: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Good afternoon.
I'm Susanne Allen.
I finished in the [inaudible] book
program at Corcoran [phonetic]
in May, and while I
was in the program,
received the Denker fellowship,
and it was great honor
to receive a fellowship of an honor
of such a beloved member
of your chapter.
While I was in the
Corcoran, I did a short paper
on a man names Simon Bening, who you
will see in this talk is the father
of the [inaudible] I'm
going to talk about.
He lived in the 1500s, 1400s, 1500s.
He was an illuminator
of manuscripts.
He was a painter, a [inaudible],
and he was at the top of his art.
He was one of the most well-known
illuminators in Europe at the time.
So I'll talk about
him a little bit more.
So we're going to talk
about Levina Teerlinc.
Pantrix [phonetic] is
the feminine of painter.
Levina Teerlinc was a rarity.
She was a successful
woman artist [inaudible].
She served all four Tudor
monarchs, in particular Elizabeth I.
She was a simple woman
and friend to Elizabeth,
and she painted miniature
portraits of the queen.
Teerlinc was born 1510
to 1520 in Flanders,
the eldest of Simon
Bening's five daughters,
and the only one known
to work as an artist.
Her heritage as illuminator,
miniaturist, scribner [phonetic]
and calligrapher can be traced
to her father and grandfather.
Simon and Sanders Bening,
masters of a specialized art form,
the illuminated manuscript.
They worked with other noted
painters on the Grimani Breviary,
circa 1510, which is
a book of prayers.
The Grimani Breviary has 1670 pages
of which 120 are full
page miniatures.
It represents the height of Flemish
manuscripts within the nation.
The Marfond [phonetic] Library
at Yale University holds a
facsimile copy of the Breviary,
and one of their curators
said, "the borders of this page
and many others throughout
the Breviary are filled
with exquisite [inaudible]
depictions of natural forms.
The [inaudible] elements are a
hallmark of the Bening studio."
It was famous for these
vary naturalistic borders.
Miniatures developed
from the tradition
of religious manuscript
illumination.
The miniatures in the
Grimani Breviary are part
of an enormous book,
while Teerlinc's miniatures
were usually painted
in vellum glued to playing cards.
They could be as small as a
little over 1-1/2 inches by less
than 1-1/4 inches, to the works
I will show you are engaged,
excuse me, enlarged many times.
Working on a tiny surface,
Teerlinc created realistic images
of Elizabeth and other
figures in the court.
An accident at birth sent
Teerlinc on her career path.
She had no brother to take
over her father's studio,
so Simon taught her his art.
His studio produced
magnificent one of a kind books,
but as Susan James says in the
feminine dynamic in English art,
"Simon Bening took Flemish
illumination to its final zenith.
It was an art form which became
obsolete upon his death."
Illuminated manuscripts were in
decline because of the invention
of the printing press
and movable type,
but Teerlinc's skills
were transferable.
She used them to forge a
career in service to Royalty.
By the late 1530s, she had
finished her apprenticeship
and became a fully fledged
member of her father's workshop.
She was admitted to the Rogue
Painters Guild, which was required
for her career as a miniaturist.
She married George Teerlinc,
the son of a prosperous gentry
family between 1540 and 1542.
The couple moved to England in
1546 when Catherine Parr, the sixth
and last queen of Henry
VIII, hired Teerlinc
as court painter after
Hans Holbein died.
The Teerlincs were
invited to live in London
because Catherine Parr had learned
of Levina's skills as an artist.
George Teerlinc's career
was secondary to his wife's.
He promoted himself as an aristocrat
and became a gentleman pensioner,
the male equivalent
of a maid of honor.
This helped advance both his
and his wife's position
at the English court.
Susan Frye, author of Pens and
Needles, Women's Textualities
in Early Modern England, says,
"George may have been a dealer
in tapestries, textiles and
artwork produced in the Netherlands
and it's likely that he acted
as an agent for his wife.
Levina Teerlinc probably spent the
period immediately after her arrival
in England working for Queen
Catherine and her sister,
Ann Parr, a prominent art patron.
After Henry VIII died, Teerlinc
worked for Edward VI and Mary I,
and when Elizabeth became queen
in 1558, Teerlinc was retained
as a miniaturist for
the rest of her life.
As court painter to Elizabeth,
she was paid the salary
of 40 pounds a year.
In addition, she received 20 pounds
a year directly from Elizabeth.
This was twice what Hans Holbein had
received and more than the salary
of Nicholas Hilliard, a
celebrated court painter,
who is better known
today than Teerlinc.
Hilliard's salary did not reach
40 pounds a year until 1599.
Another woman artist,
Susanna Horenbout paved
the way for Teerlinc.
She was from the Netherlands and was
active from the 1520s to the 1540s.
She was trained by her father,
the artist Gerard Horenbout,
and her brother, Lucas, was
a well-known miniaturist.
Henry VIII brought the
Horenbout family to England
to paint portrait miniatures
and illuminated manuscripts.
Horenbout may have
lived into the 1550s.
By 1554 or earlier, she had died.
Now I'll talk about Teerlinc's work.
Teerlinc worked for Edward
VI, Henry VIII's son.
In summer of 1547 at the beginning
of Edward's reign, Teerlinc appears
on the list of the King's artists.
Her appearance on this list
was a unique achievement
for a 16th century woman, and
it's even more significant
because she is listed first.
The record shows that in 1552,
Teerlinc presented a group
of miniatures to the King
as a New Year's gift.
When Mary came to the
thrown in 1553,
Teerlinc was retained
as court painter.
The earliest surviving examples of
Teerlinc's art is a portrait of Mary
on the Coram Rege Roll
of October 1553.
Coram Rege Rolls were records of
the proceedings of the King's bench
where the text of the roll always
began with a capital P for pasita,
which is a public port or assembly.
Mary's portrait was
painted within the P,
but you can't see the whole P,
but you can see Mary's portrait.
The P is surrounding the
portrait, but I can't,
I'm not able to show you the
whole letter P. Also for Mary,
Teerlinc made an illuminated
manuscript, Queen Mary's manual
for blessing cramp rings
and touching for the evil,
the rituals of the royal
healing ceremonies.
This is circa 1553 to 1558, so
it could have been about in any
of the five years of Mary's reign.
Cramp rings were given to women to
ward off the pain of menstruation
and childbirth, and I don't
know what they looked like.
[laughter] So that's
the description.
And here is the manuscript.
Touching for the evil refers
to the ritual of the king
or queen touching a person
suffering from scropula [phonetic],
and inflammation of the lymph glands
that can cause hearing
loss and blindness.
The recto [phonetic] is titled, the
Ceremony for the Healing of Them
that be Diseased with
the King's Evil.
The borso [phonetic] shows
Mary applying the royal touch.
And there she is.
There's a little boy,
a little [inaudible],
and she's applying
the touch [inaudible].
When Elizabeth became queen in
1558, Teerlinc became a gentlewoman
and friend to the monarch.
She was talented at
making her way in court.
Susan James says although
technically a royal servant,
Teerlinc appears to have been
accepted at the English court
as an honorary aristocrat.
She had known Elizabeth since
the latter was 11 years old.
Because of her presence
in the royal chamber,
Teerlinc had significant
influence with the queen.
In Elizabeth's court, New
Year's Day was an occasion
for giving lavish gifts.
From 1558 to 1576, Teerlinc
painted miniatures that she gave
to the queen as New Year's gifts.
This is a partial list of her
work, and these are extracts
from the official records so you see
the differences in the spellings.
[ Background Noise ]
In a box finally painted, look at
the way finely painted is spelled.
And finely painted on the first
line, 1559, is spelled differently.
And her last name, Terlyng,
there's another spelling
of Terling, and Taolyng.
So the spellings are not consistent
at all, the spellings of her name.
Elizabeth did not like to sit
for portraits, but she is known
to have sat for five artists,
including Teerlinc in 1551
and Nicholas Hilliard in 1572.
Susan James says Teerlinc's
miniatures were intimate private
gifts, evidence of the close
bond shared by these two women.
Painted for the queen's eyes only,
they represent a private
conversation
between ruler and artist.
Teerlinc had access to the queen
that a male painter
would not have had.
Susan James says that
Teerlinc's work helped Mary
and Elizabeth assert their God-given
right to rule England by ensuring
that their images were
prominently displayed.
In addition to miniatures,
portraits, and manuscripts,
it's likely that Teerlinc created
[inaudible] legal documents
and designed seals,
coins, and needlework.
Scholars attribute
designs for the great seal
of Elizabeth I to Teerlinc.
The designs were executed
by another artist.
In 1573, a manual entitled A Very
Proper Treatise wherein is breefley
set forth the art of Limming,
never put in print before his time.
The title on this one
is a little different
because it's a different edition,
but it was published
anonymously in 1573.
Limming refers to miniature
painting.
James believes that
Teerlinc wrote the manual,
thus ensuring that the art of
miniature painting would be passed
onto a new generation of artist.
A Very Proper Treatise was a
detailed how to manual intended
for painters who wanted to
learn the art of miniatures.
It was useful because
miniatures were very popular
with Elizabeth in her court.
The queen exchanged them with other
European rules, women who wore them
as jewelry, and they
were given and received
in romantic and courtship rituals.
To talk about Levina
Teerlinc's work,
I need to also discuss
Nicholas Hilliard.
Hilliard lived from 1547 to 1619,
so he was 30 to 40 years
younger than Teerlinc.
In about 1570, Hilliard
became a miniature painter
to Queen Elizabeth.
Thus, Teerlinc and Hilliard were
painting miniatures during the same
period since Teerlinc
lived until 1576.
Roy Strong, a prominent art
historian, and Susan James believed
that Teerlinc taught
Nicholas Hilliard his art.
But art historians differ in their
opinions about which Teerlinc
or Hilliary executed some of
the works and caution is needed.
Some works originally attributed
to Hilliard have been more
recently attributed to Teerlinc,
especially by feminist art critics.
Teerlinc did not sign her
work, and very few miniatures
from this period exist, to
attribution is difficult.
Roy Strong and other critics
have associated Teerlinc
with an important miniature
known as an Elizabethan Maundy.
Painted around 1565, it illustrates
the queen washing the feet
of poor women on Maundy Thursday,
the day before Good Friday.
However, Susan James believes
Teerlinc did not paint
this miniature.
The Lute miniature, circa 1574
to 1576, has been attributed
to both Hilliard and Teerlinc.
Strong and other scholars
have associated Teerlinc
with less sophisticated
miniature portraits of Elizabeth
as princess and as queen.
And this is Elizabeth as a princess,
and you can see how
small the diameter is.
This is thousands of times bigger.
This is Elizabeth as
queen of England.
This is a miniature of Lady
Catherine Grey, Elizabeth's cousin
and a possible successor
to the throne.
This is Mary Dudley, Lady Sidney.
And this is Lady Hunsdon [phonetic].
These are some of Teerlinc's
miniatures.
Strong writes that in these
miniatures and Elizabethan Maundy,
the figures are not
particularly well drawn.
They are typically elongated, and
the arms are always very thin.
You can see them there,
very thin arms.
He says the draftsman ship is weak
and the painting is thin; however,
he also says that Teerlinc's
work shows a degree
of innovation in subject matter.
Her miniatures may be
lacking in technique,
but the fact that they were
created by a woman artist
in the Tudor era makes them notable.
A side-by-side comparison
of Teerlinc's
and Hilliard's work shows
differences in technique.
The rose is miniature on the right,
is generally attributed to Hilliard.
The miniature shows
great delicacy of touch,
and Elizabeth's expression
is serene.
The miniature of Elizabeth as
queen of England attributed
to Teerlinc is less refined.
It shows a more girlish
queen with an expression
that is not uncheerful
but also a little blank.
Susan Durand in the
Myth of Elizabeth says
that in Hilliard's miniature the
white roses in Elizabeth's hair
and pinned to her dress signify the
chastity of a marriageable maiden.
The same flowers are
present in portraits
of other young unmarried women.
In the queen's black and white
costume, white symbolizes purity,
simplicity, faithfulness and
joy, all desirable qualities
in a woman seeking
a marriage partner.
In this case, black stands for
constancy, not [inaudible].
During the first eight months of
1572, Elizabeth was negotiating
for marriage with the French
Duke of Anjou, and it's likely
that the miniature was
painted with this in mind.
I've talked about Levina's work.
Let me give you a little more
information on the rest of her life.
In 1547 or 1548, Levina and George
Teerlinc traveled back to Flanders.
She was pregnant on their return
to English, and her son, Marcus,
was born in 1548 or 1549
in Calet [phonetic].
Calet belonged to English
at the time,
and the Teerlincs wanted their son
to be a subject of the English crown
so he could inherit
property in English.
In 1566, her husband leased land
in Stepney, a district of London,
and built a house for the
large sum of 500 pounds.
The same year, she and her husband
and son became English citizens.
Little known today, her
career almost entirely exists
by her successor Hilliard.
Teerlinc is nevertheless an example
of a talented women succeeding
in a field dominated by men.
Look closely, and you will find her.
First, in her father's
workshop, learning her trade,
and later painting with a minute
brush on a tiny piece of velum,
capturing Elizabeth's likeness
for the queen's pleasure
and for foreign princes
and diplomats.
Teerlinc died on June 23,
1576, probably in Stepney.
She was between 56 and 66 years
old at the time of her death.
She was buried at the St.
Dunstan Parish church in Stepney.
No portrait of her has been found.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Are there questions or?
>> George Barnum: We'll
do questions at the end.
>> Susanne Allen: At the end, okay.
>> Malia Balas: Hello everyone.
My name is Malia Balas, and
first I want to thank you all
for having me here to share my
testimonial with all of you.
I'm here to talk about my
experience and how I grew
into the [inaudible] love
throughout my years of college.
First, to give you a brief
background about me, I was born
and raised in the Pocono Mountains
in Pennsylvania, and I'm the oldest
of three siblings and
the first in my family
to pursue a degree
in the field of arts.
Though I excelled in other fields,
I felt that my passion [inaudible],
so my parents were extremely
supportive and not at all surprised,
especially when I chose a
competitive program really close
to home.
So then I began my studies
as a communication student
at [inaudible] University.
Fast forward to my sophomore year.
It's the spring of 2014, and
everyone was starting to line
up their summer jobs,
and I was not having it
with going back to
the retail business.
I was ready to get work in the
program that I was growing to love.
I wanted to do something
with design,
so I approached professor
Ann Lemon [phonetic],
who came here with me today
to see if she had any advice.
I didn't have any classes under
her instruction, but she seemed
like a very approached and
sociable lady, so I thought, hey,
maybe she has some advice
that she could give me.
And she told me, well, I'll
keep my eyes open to see
if anybody wants a sophomore
on their team, but hey,
I'm doing this project
over the summer.
One of my fellow faculty members
just donated a letter press
to the university, and I would
love to see this go up and running
so that students would
use it by the fall.
But it is a lot of work, and I
don't think I can do this on my own.
So do you want to be my intern?
And it didn't take much
thought for me to say yes,
even though I had zero knowledge
of letter press at that point.
I was ready to explore
this new form of art
that I had thought was lost in time.
So, I showed up to room 209,
and by the looks of things,
I knew I was ready to earn my keep.
I saw a stack of rusted galley trays
and composing strips in one corner,
and a box of ink that looked like it
had been resurrected from the 1960s,
and just a pile of type drawers
that had a thick layer
of dust covering it.
See many of our type drawers
had either been donated
from the university precomputer age,
or they were donated
by the local newspaper.
Regardless, the type drawers
were all being exhumed
from old dusty basements,
and they just had a piece
of cardboard duct taped
to the top of it,
so none of the pieces
were in the right spot.
So when I wasn't scrubbing rust
off of trays, I was learning
to navigate California [inaudible]
forward and backward and sideways.
We developed this machine
to try to get all the dust
out of the little nooks and
crannies of all of the type drawers.
It was a lot of work.
[laughter] It was kind
of fun though.
It was like kids on
Christmas morning or one
of our friends [inaudible] would
bring up these type drawers
from the basement,
and we'd open them,
and the reactions would vary
from, ooh, 72 [inaudible]
to like, oh 10 [inaudible].
So after a few weeks, the
room somewhat started,
maybe started to make sense.
We took a lot of supply tips and
organization tips from our friends
at Light Graffiti, and we
tweaked them around a bit
in our little 10 foot by 6 foot
room that we called a studio.
So after hours of laborious
organization,
we finally had our very own
tabletop C and D pilot press.
The room was complete with three
type drawers, one set of furniture,
and about a dozen cans
of very old paint.
Anyway, once the press
had been up and running,
we decided to name it the Landis
Press after Professor John Landis,
who had taught at [inaudible]
University.
He had taught many
of my own professors,
and he was an advocated
of hand-done work.
He really stressed the
value in taking your time
and putting the effort
into your work.
In fact, it was only when he
went on sabbatical for a semester
that the university was able to
pull the presses out of the room
and replace them with computers.
Anyway, once we had the press
up and running, we had the honor
of inviting him back for a
little induction ceremony.
They're we announced the official
opening of the press complete
with the cutting of a ribbon.
So after the press was
officially open for student use,
I was given permission by the
head of our design department
to host some group sessions in order
to give an introductory
course on letter press.
It was a simple two-hour course
where fellow students could come in
and they could see type
other than on the screen
and they could quick print
a little piece of their own
so that maybe they could use
letter presses [inaudible].
So most of my junior
year was spent teaching,
and then slowly making small
improvements to the room.
Getting new ink, procuring
more type,
and exploring new methods
of printing.
We started printing on everything,
from tape to cardboard
to linoleum block.
We had a little wall there
of our experimentation.
One of our experiments, we tried
getting these little cut pieces
of paper printed.
It comes out very good.
Fuzzy. Regardless, it
was fun experimentation.
I was able to help many of my
peers utilize the press as well.
We would make everything from
little coasters to posters
and then I would make
my own holiday cards
and spread some of those around.
We even made our own prints
to sell at local [inaudible].
So in comes my senior year,
and as part of our program,
we are to have an internship
for credit.
And I was getting ready to intern
at a small package design company
in West [inaudible],
and Ann approaches me
with a proposition of hers.
For the past few years,
she has overseen a project
for the [inaudible] historical
society and paired with them
to make a publication
entitled Along the [inaudible].
For that project, she would
pair a student or duo together,
and they would make a
nicely laid out layout book
that would be filled
with local history.
And each year the student or duo
would make a nicely laid out spread
of the book and design a dust
jacket that would be conceptual
to the theme of that year.
The year 2016 was planned to be all
about the town bicentennial
celebration.
The historical society had this idea
to create a memorabilia
of artifacts.
They had brought together all these
old items from past celebrations,
and they wanted to
put them all together
and preserve them in a book.
To make a long story
short, the two students
who had started the project,
they were amazing designers,
but they were unable to
see the project through.
So that's when Ann approached
me and asked if I would pick
up the project where
it was left off.
And it seemed like an interesting
topic as well as a great way
to build my portfolio as a senior.
So I agreed.
So as many of you are probably
aware, whenever you take
over a project from someone
else, it can be a nightmare,
and for me this was like
being handed a jigsaw puzzle
where I knew all the pieces were
there, but getting them to fit
in the right spot was a mess.
Between rebuilding a corrupted
file and then losing photos
and getting some old documents
[inaudible] the surprises never
seemed to end.
Thankfully I had some amazing
photos that were taken by one
of the previous students
who had worked on it,
and they had already started a nice
grid to work from, and thank God,
I had some of the most
patient people working with me
because this was already
about three months past due,
and there were 12 rounds
of revision between me
and getting this book off to print.
Also, while I was working
on the interior,
I was consistently tinkering
with the book's cover,
what I wanted to do for that.
The dust jackets in past
years had been letter pressed,
so we wanted to keep
that tradition going.
However, in the past years, they had
used polymer plates, and I thought,
wouldn't it be great if
we printed the jacket
with bare boned hand-set metal type.
And it seemed like a
great idea at the time,
but I did not know what I
was getting myself into.
But it would have great
historical significance.
I mean most of the type that we
had was historic to the university
or the town, and the local
paper that we featured
in the interior of the book.
Well, I don't [inaudible] that
idea in mind, and just the concept
that I would challenge myself
to make the most complicated
that I had ever attempted.
I wanted the cover to be minimal
while still stretching the idea
of what could be done with our
very modest collection of type.
I spent hours pouring over
images and tutorials of how
to make angles work with
metal type and trying
to break out of that grid.
When the interior was all about
round ten, we took this lock-up,
wrapped it in cellophane and
bubble wrap and put it in a box
and drove it down from Pennsylvania
to Delaware to our friends
at Light Graffiti, where they
helped us fill in the little gaps
that were missing in this
lock-up and assisted us
in printing the covers
on their [inaudible].
We decided that we would print
with just black and white
to match the scheme
of past celebrations
and to keep the minimal
historical feel.
The exterior of the jacket
shows the finished product,
and the interior cover
shows the lock-up
that was used to print the jacket.
So shortly after the
jackets were printed,
the interior of the book was printed
and bound as well, and in the end,
we had just over 70
copies all put together.
I worked really hard
to show off the amount
of design the Landis
Press had to offer.
Not just in the cover but
also in the chapter headers.
[ Background Noise ]
All in all, the book tells a great
story of historic [inaudible]
and memorabilia and
celebrations that have gone by.
Since graduating in the
spring, I've been working
at a small [inaudible] design
company in Westchester,
Pennsylvania just outside of Philly.
There we develop gateways and
vehicle pedestrian signage
for cities all across the nation
from Anchorage to Austin
to Annapolis.
I'm able to get back to the Landis
press every once in a while and work
on a few projects of my own.
I recently was able to print
out some Mother's Day cards
and tried my hand the first time
on wedding invitations
for a friend of mine.
My experience in letter press
and print making has allowed me
to develop a passion for
detailed and hand-done work,
and I'm extremely thankful for that.
I continue to bring that
into my work every day,
and while my current placement
does not allow me the funds
to have my own press, I plan
to one day fire one of my own
so that I can continue to push my
skills and really develop that form
of art that I have learned a lot
about for the past few years.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jodi Hoover: Hi, my
name is Jodi Hoover.
I am also very honored to be
one of your Denker fellows.
I'm here today to talk about,
a little bit about my
research and my artwork.
I am currently a part-time MFA
candidate at Towson University.
I'm also working full time as
a liberation at the University
of Maryland in Baltimore county,
which explains why I'm known
to any [inaudible] apologize.
So, and some of you may also know
me as I think this chapter has been
up to see Vivian and Edgar
[inaudible] book collection,
and I was the person like who
ran things all over the place.
I worked with them since 2001,
so, anyway, [inaudible] book.
So as an artist I've always been
interested in combining words
and images to tell stories.
My undergraduate degree is in
illustration, but I quickly realized
that commercial illustration work
was not going to be fruitful.
When I was in [inaudible] print
making and artist books that way
of working really clicked
for me because I could,
it was a way that would allow
me to tell my stories and
yet retain complete control over
my materials, over the process
that I used to bind [inaudible].
So this one of my books that is
very [inaudible] based on a couple
of Bible verses in Revelations of a
[inaudible] that destroys the world.
And this is another one
where I worked with a friend,
had taken on microfiction class
and so her story worked
really well with my books
because I like keeping
the text like very,
very minimal so that you
can actually [inaudible]
because I understand that
part of the experience
with artists' books is often
not being able to like sit
and hang out with them for hours.
So this is about, I guess
it's now a love triangle.
[laughter] So alongside
of my [inaudible] books,
I've created drawings.
The drawings were sort of
[inaudible] story telling process.
I was thinking about
snapshots, sort of a quick window
into revealing a character,
and again, you know,
they're very illustrative,
reactions [inaudible] sort of mixed.
So like some people would be like,
I don't get this [inaudible]
for it whatever.
Then some people would
comment and tell me
like really elaborates stories about
what they thought was going on.
Of course those are the
people that I loved, so,
and like sometimes they were
just about me telling jokes.
Like for [inaudible] these two
guys who, you know, they are really
into each other, but the
one doesn't have any feet,
and the other doesn't have any
wings, so this interaction was going
to be really [inaudible]
be together.
Anyway, [inaudible] studio practice
going, I've also earned a degree,
a master's degree in library
science, and I've been working
as a full-time librarian for
seven or eight years now.
And in the summer of 2013, I
was misdiagnosed, but I was told
that I was going blind,
and that there was nothing
that they could do about it.
Thankfully that was completely
untrue, but I was like,
you know what, I have an
opportunity where I can go back
to school, I'm going to do it.
So I applied to the
[inaudible] program
and started there in
the fall of 2014.
When I applied for this fellowship
and also when I started school,
I really thought that I was going
be doing a lot of print making,
that I was going to be doing
some letter press work,
and I have done a little bit
of that, but as, you know,
our programs sometimes go,
once you're there you end up doing
something completely different.
So we're going to talk about
drawing because [inaudible].
But in case you don't know,
Towson actually has a
quite lovely print shop.
And that's another picture.
In the beginning of every
semester they don't let students
into the shop until they
can pass a skills test,
so there's some beautiful few weeks
where like only grad students
have the combination to shops,
and if you want to go in
and use like three tables
and like all the things, you can
because no one else is there.
So that is me being really happy
when I believe Saturday night
when I was a giant nerd and ended
up at the shop by myself for hours.
So my research interests have
ended up moving down [inaudible].
My family is Pennsylvania German.
I don't know, if you guys know,
Pennsylvania German
groups are actually divided
into two categories.
There's the fancy Pennsylvania
Germans.
Those are the ones that
have the [inaudible] signs.
Mostly I believe Lutheran
and Methodist,
and then there's the plain
Pennsylvania Germans,
and those are the Amish
and Mennonite.
The Amish and the Mennonites
only [inaudible] 25 percent
of Pennsylvania German population
[inaudible] so a small percent.
And my family is Mennonite
from Lancaster county.
And so I started looking
at traditional Amish
and Mennonite quilting patterns,
so not the block designs,
but the actual hand-stitched
quilting patterns, and taking a look
at the different variations
used in those.
So this one is from a book
that I was looking at.
The one on the right is
quilted by my grandmother,
who was an amazing
quilter and also a painter
and furniture maker [inaudible]
really not much she couldn't do.
In addition, I also started
looking at Pennsylvania [inaudible],
which I was not previously aware of.
These were things created
mostly between 1740 and 1860.
Generally small, always on paper,
colored with ink rather than paint.
And they were used to
commemorate important events,
so like a birth or a baptism.
More prevalent within the
fancy Pennsylvania groups
but also [inaudible].
For me and my aesthetic, I was
delighted to discover, you know,
beautiful, crazy flowers
and creatures and just sort
of some beautiful folk art design
work that really appealed to me.
There's been a lot written on
what the different things mean.
Some people are like flowers
mean one thing, and you know,
the lady with wings is an angel,
the different kinds of birds
and different things, but what I
found really interesting is there's
also just some weird stuff that
people cannot fully explain.
Like mermaids show up.
Now they are no longer [inaudible]
bible or in Pennsylvania [laughter],
so it's just kind of
this weird thing,
but they're like I don't know
why they decided on mermaids,
but it's something that
definitely shows up.
So I started to draw, and you know,
these were just some early drawings
where I was looking at different
ways that I could combine
that sort aesthetic [inaudible] into
the way that I like to see things.
The radio towers always
appeared in my other drawings,
sort of [inaudible] communication.
So I was playing around with that.
And then as I was going through
this process, I started to think
about ways that I could get text
incorporated into the drawings.
And [inaudible] story telling.
I went back to my roots,
my illustration roots,
and was really looking at a lot
of different children's
books and reading.
There was not a lot of critical
analysis of children's book art.
There should be, but there is not.
So I was reading some things
about that, but really thinking
about how-- because if
anybody is trying to write
for children's books,
right, it's hard.
People will tell you it's one
of the most difficult types
of writing that's done because we
have to communicate a lot of things
in some very simple sentences,
and then thinking a way
that that hangs out and [inaudible].
So these are just [inaudible]
books in my collection.
And so this is kind
of where we end up.
So one of the pieces I've
been working on recently.
This was the first one and what
turned into a series of three.
It fairly large for me.
It's 42 x 34, and so it's
on [inaudible] paper,
and the final piece is then
stretched like a canvas
after the drawing was finished,
so it was a little nerve wracking.
I actually drew [inaudible]
picture [inaudible]
and so what I was doing is
once the paper was [inaudible],
I have it out on the table,
and I use acrylic ink.
And because the paper is treated,
the ink doesn't dry right away,
so as the ink is drying I
come back into the studio
and tip the paper to make it run.
And then that dictated
the structure.
So those drips became the building,
and somebody that is used to working
with like a pretty tight sketch,
particularly when I go
to something this large.
I [inaudible] so it's
just as it progressed,
I would start adding things
in but not really knowing
like how things were going to layer.
I used a projector and took the
quilt patterns the stitching
patterns and project them onto
the paper, and then pencil
and paint them in, which is every
bit as time consuming as it sounds,
and considering how much I
resisted learning how to quilt,
like I can barely sew,
my grandmother would have
thought this was hilarious
because it is actually very similar
to how you would put the patterns
on the fabric in order
to quilt them.
So one of the last things I did
with this was put in the text.
It was [inaudible] access
point for the drawing
where like I was creating
this really weird drawing,
and people needed to have some sort
of way to enter that and just sort
of get an idea of where I am.
Specifically I went with [inaudible]
but there will come a point
where that is difficult for
people to read, and so it sort of,
there's a point at which, I don't
know, it means more of a mystery.
To get some of that
texture on the little house,
it's like a thin paper
collage and then oil pastel,
so I'll show you on
one of the others.
There's a lot of dimension
to the drawings.
This was the second one in
that series that [inaudible]
so again using that same
technique I just sort of,
the ogre didn't actually appear in
this until about halfway through.
I wasn't sure.
And the full sentence is the
ogre regretted her choice,
and I know that it's
supposed to be ogress,
but ogress is a terrifying
word, so I changed to ogre.
And then you can see hopefully
a little bit on the drawing
on the right taken at an angle, so
I used thin paper to sort of build
up that figure so it really
has a texture [inaudible].
[Inaudible] so the
little [inaudible] guy
that we're moving through, I
mean I think this is happy ending
because the wind is happy.
It might not be as happy because of
the little masked buy, I don't know.
We're going to [inaudible].
And this one too, again, using those
quilt patterns as a way to enhance
and obscure and really
messing around with the idea
that the space can be three
dimensional but also flat as I went
through and kind of hidden,
kind of put that leftward
fadeout even on the paper.
This was one that I
recently finished.
It doesn't have the text, but
I used [inaudible] that ended
up getting wrecked for
reasons we won't go into.
This is actually on canvas,
so it's drawing on canvas.
I refer to them as drawings,
and we're probably
[inaudible] at this point.
And again the house shows
up, and [inaudible].
And then I added in, I was looking
the Victorian era children's books
with the black and white
drawings, and added in this bunny.
The title is [inaudible] were
small, and I [inaudible] sort
of a fairy god mother,
guardian angel type thing
but also a little ominous
because we don't know [inaudible].
I will show you very quickly
this exceptionally [inaudible]
of a drawing that I'm
currently working on,
although is on canvas,
so [inaudible].
Again, the flowers, the types
of things you're going to see
in the [inaudible] examining
the ink, as a way of sort
of forming like [inaudible].
I think this is going to be about
bees, but the bees haven't shown
up yet, but I'm confident
that they will,
nor have I completely decided what
sort of text [inaudible] with this.
[Inaudible] a couple
details of how that looks.
Again, this is kind
of like [inaudible].
It's like 30 by 40, I
think, 32 by 40 or so.
They're fairly large.
What's next?
I am going to hang it up, going to
be in an exhibition in the spring
with [inaudible] artist
named Rob Blair [phonetic].
He does ceramic monsters that are
very like mechanical, like crazy,
[inaudible] so I think that
my like nature monsters,
fairytale monsters will
fit in well with his.
Because I'm part-time and because
the Towson program is 60 credits,
so normally going full time
it would take me three years.
I won't finish until
the fall of 2018,
so I'll be around as
a student for a bit.
There is definitely some
more books in here somewhere.
It's just, you know, not
right now, but I find time.
So I expect more books.
I play around with things and will
definitely get there, but thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> George Barnum: Questions?
[ Background Noise ]
>> Your illustrations with
[inaudible] reminded me,
you're [inaudible] you're
going through [inaudible] side
of the building which I think
has a [inaudible] is very similar
[inaudible], but I was struck
by thinking, as a civic gesture,
these would have made
a terrific mural.
>> Jodi Hoover: That
would be really large.
But I was reading a book about
an octopus when I drew that in,
so it is not, it's not
completely [inaudible].
>> I think a story, I think
a story board and book
through several blocks of the
city would be really [inaudible].
[laughter]
>> In a working day.
>> Jodi Hoover: And also
I have a lot of free time.
[laughter]
>> I have a question for Susanne.
I love your [inaudible].
So Levina Teerlinc, I mean, is there
more like research that you want
to do looking at that period?
More that you want to find,
or is there, do we know all
that can be known about
Levina Teerlinc.
>> Susanne Allen: I
don't think we do.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> How many other women
artists are there?
>> Susanne Allen: Not very many.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
I believe that the low countries
had more of a tradition [inaudible].
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> And I don't know if it's really
true or not, but I was trained
and told that you can sometimes
spot women's [inaudible]
because they [inaudible]
so what should be bold is
painted yellow instead of gold,
and that's actually [inaudible].
>> Susanne Allen: That's
interesting.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> I'm curious, is there a reason
as to why they couldn't [inaudible].
>> I don't think it's
because of some evil property
of the metal [inaudible] value and--
>> Susanne Allen: They
weren't trusting them.
>> They were trusted [inaudible].
>> Jodi Hoover: Well, I was
curious because it would be
like not trust [inaudible]
did something happen.
>> [Inaudible] maybe they had some
notion that they'll see themselves
in the reflection of the gold,
and you know, [inaudible].
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> Susanne Allen: Well, I
was, I love, her father,
Simon Bening was great,
great [inaudible] he was one
of the last of the great ones.
And [inaudible] gradually going
away because of the printing press.
Bibles could be printed.
And so I was interested in her
father's work, and after I found
out he had five daughters and
one of them was an artist,
that's how I got interested in her,
I wanted to learn more about her.
Yeah.
[ Background Noise ]
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Malia Balas: Yes, I have
since graduated and passed it
on to a successor sort of,
who's a senior right now
at [inaudible] University,
and she took over my job
and overseeing the press and
leading some group instruction.
>> So is there a particular
program for it or is it something
that design people or other
art people who [inaudible].
>> Malia Balas: Well, as
far as the university,
there's no like letter
press initiative
or class or anything like that.
This is something that we thought
would just really enhance the
communication design
department's ability
to understand type
and have [inaudible].
>> The rogue nature of your
whole assignment reminds me
of [inaudible].
She several years back now
really kick started her campaign
when she bought a--
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, a truck, and
outfitted it with a whole--
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> [Inaudible] truck girl.
>> Yeah, [inaudible] your whole
project was called movable type--
>> Malia Balas: Yeah.
>> And she drove around the
country and stopped in school yards
and shopping malls and
showed people how to print.
But your story has very much
that nature, and I just noticed
on Facebook that she's busy making
a new truck, so I'm not sure,
maybe [inaudible] cross country.
>> And some of us have
[inaudible] and all that.
>> Malia Balas: We left some
rusted trays in the corner.
It was like an initiative
to enter our program.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
>> Oh, I had a comment
about the mermaids
and someone else might be
more of an expert than I am,
but I have this memory of the
mermaid as a symbol for some branch
of the French aristocracy I think.
There is a, and it
became a printer's mark
on the [inaudible], yeah.
>> Jodi Hoover: They actually do
think that because they were looking
at printed material from Europe
that that is a connection,
but it wouldn't have meant the
same things to them at all.
But there's a couple,
there's a couple instances too
where the wonder [inaudible] shows
up, which is like the man fish
with like feet and [inaudible],
and like they think that it was
printed on paper that came through
and so, those sorts of bits
were collected as inspiration,
but disconnected from the meaning.
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> George Barnum: Well I think one
of the things that has impressed us,
now all three times, is not only
the quality of these presentations,
over all [inaudible],
but the variety,
and I think this is very much
in the spirit of the person
in whose honor we are here.
He would be [inaudible].
We have a small token of
appreciation for the three
of you, our chapter [inaudible].
[ Inaudible Comments ]
I also need to say as usual, and
we can never say this enough times,
our thanks to Martin [inaudible].
>> Oh, yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> George Barnum: [Inaudible]
for hosting us so graciously,
and we have some [inaudible].
>> I'm always happy
to have you here.
>> George Barnum: So, [inaudible]
there are, there's a little bit
of [inaudible] over
there on the table.
There are pickup cards
about the chapter
and about the Denker fellowship
[inaudible] also there.
>> Please take one of
the [inaudible] that one
of our former Denker
fellows, [inaudible].
I think there are enough
for everybody.
>> George Barnum: And thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.